on se la carrer mais oui on a suivi
ensemble à vos côtés cette cette
séquence cette intervention du chef du
chef de l'état emmanuel macron qu on a
aussi entendu
se justifier ou en tout cas tenté
d'expliquer d'argumenter ses récents
propos qui lui ont valu une polémique je
rappelle cette phrase la russie ne doit
pas être humilié alors c'est vrai qu
emmanuel macron a souligné qu'il avait
toujours été clair le terme de clarté
est revenu à maintes reprises lors de sa
prise de parole mais c'est vrai aussi
que on avait plutôt mal perçu le fait
que selon lui il ne fallait pas humilier
la russie alors il a un petit peu changé
un petit peu changé sa façon de voir les
choses en réalité parce que là il dit
lorsque l'ukraine aura gagné c'est pas
du tout l'hypothèse qu'il avait émis au
moment où il avait évoqué cette
nécessité de ne pas humilier la russie
là clairement il dit qu'il faut parler
mais une fois que tout sera terminé en
quelque sorte soit une victoire de
l'ukraine soit une volonté des deux
belligérants de venir à la table des
négociations
donc ils précisent un peu les choses et
c'est une façon d'évacuer les critiques
qui ont pu lui être adressées ces
derniers temps il a sans cesse répété
que la france avait été en première
ligne côté de l'europe pour mettre en
place des sanctions pour apporter une
aide financière pour apporter une aide
militaire à l'ukraine et il tente de
balayer en quelque sorte toutes les
critiques qui ont pu souligner la
tiédeur ou le retrait relatif de la
france sur cette question et chrétienne
et puis il y a urgence à aller du côté
de l'ukraine me james andré l'a rappelé
il n'y a pas beaucoup de doutes quant à
ce voyage du côté de kiev mais il ya
aussi une volonté de maintenir un petit
peu en haleine ya une forme de
storytelling voulu de la part de
l'elysée pour que finalement il y ait
une dimension plus dramatique est que
emmanuel macron qui avait souligné qu'il
ne se rendrait qu'à kiev lorsque et bien
ça sera nécessaire eh bien on est en
train d'expliquer que désormais c'est
nécessaire que le président de la
république s'y rendent et il faut
rappeler aussi qu'il y a cette demande
de kiev qui a été exprimée il ya à peu
près deux semaines il faut que emmanuel
macro bien avant que la france ne soit
plus présidente en exercice de l'union
européenne